[Musik]
willst du ich dachte was zum ersten mal
ich wachse auch zum ersten mal dafür
musste ich dann aber ganz schön
einstecken
ich habe meiner kindheit nicht mit
puppen häuschen gespielt ich habe mit
den jungs unterwegs
da wird man nicht sehen weil ich so bist
du dann aufgewachsen in gruppe a wurde
für steinkohle für die industrie
abgebaut oder ja dafür ist das gebiet
besonders bekannt während der
industrialisierung hat es angefangen und
danach verwandelten sich die ganzen
kleinen städtchen nach und nach während
des wirtschaftlichen aufschwungs und
großstädten kraftwerken wir arbeiten ja
und je mehr arbeitet desto mehr arbeit
der jungs die frech werden konnten
dann bist du von dort weggezogen
als ich mit dem studium angefangen habe
das vor gebiet hat seinen charme
aber es sind alles arbeiter städte und
die sind alle nicht besonders schön
im krieg wurde viel variiert oder ja ich
beklage mich auch nicht ich sage nur
dass es schönere orte gibt
ich habe keine ahnung kann es mir ja
klar ja warte